yo me and my homies were sitting here
trying to make hands now we're building
empires we call it be friends drew all
those pictures all by myself you like up
at the elephant i like entrepreneur elf
[Laughter]
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
i'm going somewhere to do a podcast
which will be a lot of fun it's a little
skateboard culture out here in l.a
drock's here
and then we will head over to the green
street festivities do a bunch of
cannabis industry stuff on that front it
should be a fun day now i'm about to
jump into twitter spaces with russell
wilson quarterback the denver broncos
that feels weird to say hi everybody
it's gary vaynerchuk what's important to
me is that my new york jets go to denver
and defeat russell this season the
schedule is out i've circled the date
russ i'm very focused i'm focused right
now unfortunately you dictate a lot i'll
be sitting in the sands dictating
nothing
um but i'm still focused
oh i don't think actually russell you'll
love this as much as i love you and that
you're being very gracious i will buy my
own tickets right behind the jets bench
i will talk to no one i will wear six
different jets jerseys because i need to
pull off which one i need during that
drive and i'm a maniac for this stuff
but i just want to say hi to everybody
i'm excited to be on here with the whole
crew you know
i'm curious with you like knowing how
we're gonna change the game for the
sports drinks where do you see local
weather in the next 5 10 20 years from
now well i i hope it's the the number
one drink in the world in terms of the
only way to think the reason russ is a
super bowl winning
quarterback is because his answer right
there like why
like why wouldn't you
want that like
confidence and and ambition
is not delusional ego it's a framework
of perspective to try like when i say i
want the friends
to be disney
i want to be friends to be disney like
why wouldn't i
i'm not saying
be friends is going to be better than
disney that's a different sentence i'm
looking to build my disney why wouldn't
i and for all of you like dreaming and
and strategizing
and then executing it's important if you
don't have that perspective if you shoot
for the top of that house
you're definitely not going to a
mountain
if you shoot for the moon you're by
accident going to end up on that
mountain on your way to the moon
i appreciate your words man i appreciate
my man i will love you this entire
lifetime except for the three and a half
hours we play each other
seem like every cat ain't gotta maintain
the cap you can make change don't change
for that tell the whole truth get paid
for that bet you never fall off you was
made for that you gotta all right this
is nice from 22 to 34 never making that
much money i was happy as [ __ ] and that
structure was already built in i was
happy as [ __ ] you did what you loved
yeah i was happy as [ __ ] there's like
like you know like we could break we
could break it down a million different
ways i was happy as [ __ ]
more importantly big kudos to my mother
i was happy as [ __ ] from 5 to 15 where
we really didn't have [ __ ]
so i think the luckiest person on earth
is someone that's born into nothing
who's happy every day because she or he
when they become an adult realize
compoundly black and white obvious
that money does not equate to happiness
right right
right because if you fall into a lot and
you're happy you might consciously and
subconsciously think the money made you
happy we went on nice vacations dinners
if you're born into nothing and your
household is unhappy you think money
will get you out of it sure but if
you're born into nothing and you're
happy the whole time boy are you on a
foundation
for everybody who's listening they're
like who doesn't have money it's like
[ __ ] you who gives a [ __ ] like easy for
you to say you have it now but the
answer is i have it now what they don't
know is how much happiness happened in
the first 35 years of my life without it
so it's not like it's not like i don't
know yeah i love when people talk like i
lived it i lived not making 100 000 a
year for the majority of my life a
hundred now people talking billions and
millions yeah people don't feel they're
sick like people feel like being a
millionaire is like entry level
but it's not there's a lot of different
ways to live life but if you can live
within your means
and not keep up with the joneses and not
let other people's judgment cast on you
you can have a much happier life
that was great man wow i hope everybody
enjoys this [ __ ] because i thoroughly
enjoyed it thank you
thank you brother that's [ __ ] amazing
they will i think a board here too that
i think you might like
dude
oh my god
dude can you ship it sure please cause i
really want to rock that in my office
[Music]
i feel a little bit in a good spot where
i don't feel like i have to win the day
as much if i was a rapper i would have
built my career by being
on features of people's albums and my
mindset going to the studio would be to
be so good that every fan of that rapper
would become a fan of mine
and i think i've brought that energy to
podcasts for the last decade
but i think that also makes me go 15
too far
which makes me not liked by a certain
percentage of the audience and i feel
like that 15
is down to like three percent and i felt
it and this was really
really happy with that podcast
paid off 60 000 in debt told you
my friend it's not something you should
worry about it's something that you
should be grateful for what you're
seeing right now is where i wanna go
with my social content which is i'm most
comfortable and enjoy q a right i'm
gonna go a lot more into it and i'm
excited about i think it's gonna lead to
more compelling content something that
brings more value right now
i'm putting myself in the most
interesting framework which is q and
paper
love blueberries
and this is the festival when my dude
quit it was running the production and
i'm paying attention
so that's how much quick this will move
you know
but anyway but everyone's very excited
we're pulling it off and got the permits
and
you're here and you know blueberries are
delicious there's gonna be too many
people oh yeah we got uh there's a
coffee thing and a tea thing and [ __ ]
and some of your voices and some oatmeal
[ __ ]
and anything else there's like
restaurants
you're the reason i'm here 300 and
something cold emails and uh he answered
i followed through with all the stuff
you know
just to work for free for the defense
yeah permission to get that knowledge
get that experience good for you brother
i'm proud of you yes really nice to meet
you i want to tell you something this
building is so nice
this building the vibes is good the
owner is good the people they are gold
your vibes are good thank you her vibes
are good thank you you're good
thank you and you're drawing randy the
macho man savage my favorite wrestler of
all time of all time oh yeah
black and white
[Music]
i know that
drock brought up again he brought up
once before he's like why don't you get
a coach i was like oh that might make
sense when i do it sometimes i'll like
the reason it doesn't work for me is
when i make pretend and i do it yeah i
can get the first line off
but where i struggle is i try to rhyme
the last word of the cadence which i
know is not the like that's 1985 when it
was like it's so much more advanced but
what's interesting that my brain does is
i'll rhyme it with a non-word oh yeah
yeah just a sound like a rhyming just
like yeah i'm just trying to rhyme like
death with and i'll say schmath instead
of like liquid that like i don't i don't
know what to do yeah
what is that you gotta reverse the the
cadence so
most people say the line they want to
say like yo i'm sipping on a liquid
death and uh
right that's what i did so the key to
what i do for freestyling on top is to
reverse that so i say yo i smack a
rapper down with the rhyme tackles my
lyrics is sharp just like a pineapple so
it starts with rhyme tackle and then
goes pineapple because you knew you
wanted pineapple so you set up the other
one first exactly
so you look around the room and do it
like that if it's fiji don't say fiji
first because what if you can't pull out
something that rhymes with fiji on top
right
so when i was imagining like straight
out of belarus i've got to have belarus
figured first go with that and then hit
it first said i get hella loose
like i'm straight out of belarus right
i think when i win my grammy i'll be
like i gotta give a big shout out
he told me to start with the second
mama we did it
there's a lot of people in this room
that are going to resonate with this
people that say gary you don't get it
i'm a perfectionist
the way my brain takes that is no you
don't get it you're scared
you're scared to put it out and you're
trying to make it look cute by saying
you're a perfectionist that's just
makeup for insecurity
and that's what you're basically saying
people are scared to talk about
the [ __ ] they actually care about
they're scared to put out the content
that they actually want to put out
because they're addicted
to the metrics of social media
because somebody knows that they
normally get 500 likes or 50 likes
they're going to keep making the same
[ __ ] even if their brain and their soul
has evolved to a new place because they
don't have the humility or the
self-confidence
and
they're deploying insecurity
and it's a huge deal are we ready for
this oh pledge of allegiance please
heads up
[Music]
that was incredible thank you so much
you're really addicted to the bubble
hockey
me and my boys are sitting here
collabing we're thinking about caleb and
babin you know you're both here to hear
what i got to say we're going to be
blowing by this highway like it's like
it's a lot easier a lot easier yo me and
my homies we're sitting here trying to
make ends now we're building empires we
call it be friends drew all those
pictures all by myself you like up at
the elephant i like entrepreneur
thing starting to like build a little
bit but getting to the fourth line
is gonna be interesting
i'm more interested in
talking to the individuals that thought
it was a good use of energy to tell
somebody else that they weren't going to
win
if they put their mind to something
that's the compassion and sympathy i
have for the people that
are hurting inside so much
that it's interesting for them
to try to stop others from seeking out
their happiness because they themselves
are not ready to seek out their
happiness
some fire right there
right that was a good one right yeah
that last little part's interesting
really
see this is the problem we've been
trying to tell you
i need a new phone
i think so
look at that camera in different it's so
cool it's so much different
that's wild
[Music]
1 37 pm in the building at green street
festival gary yes
we know you don't smoke correct
but if you did yes the dream blunt
rotation who would be in the mix yes
ms
iraq
l.a
and moose
why you ask those are my four college
friends who smoked eight blunts to the
face a day and for four years
desperately tried to get me to puff up
and i held off but if i did it it would
be with the mal ida boys baby has one of
those apes on his neck yes
if you want me to be like that before be
friends and to just have a [ __ ]
puffin on my face or something like this
little pumpkin i got some real estate
right here i can see that being like
cool look that would be a tremendous
priority of mine
i'll talk to your whole team about it
we are at a week convention
how many businesses in the cannabis
space are you involved with and where do
you think that the real opportunities
and growth are in this case uh so i'm
i'm a large investor in a company called
green street that is run by rama that's
why i'm here that's what this is all
about
underneath that rama's got a ton of
stuff we've got a brand called astrix
and tcj which is a lot of fun to be to
be transparent i'm a non-operating
partner in green street so i'm not even
sure how many things rama has going on
aboard the money and i'm there for that
phone
the space overall super interesting i
grew up in the liquor business which is
regulated state by state so when
cannabis started getting legalized and
when i could see the country was finally
ready to get over to hoop on it i was
like okay uh this is something i want to
learn so i'm still in the
learning phase
you know i'm uh i'm on the board of a
company called rib capital out of
canada
um so i'm really in collecting
information mode
because this is inevitable
like for the rest of our lives
like there will only be more
acceptance so i think my destiny long
term is to be involved on the brand side
we'll see um but uh but it's a very
interesting space i mean i hate when
people like i literally have meetings
with some people old heads who try to
[ __ ] on it while they're drinking
a [ __ ] cocktail and i'm like you do
understand in 19 20 and 30 people said
the same thing about alcohol
everything's [ __ ] up when it's off
balance but in balance everything can be
appropriate and so i think i think i'm
excited that the stigma is going away
and i think we can have far healthier
conversations around it in the next
decade
[Applause]
would you be more likely to invest in a
cannabis startup that had
mediocre product and incredible
marketing
or incredible product
mediocre marketing
oh yeah the first one's gonna work
because most people don't know what the
[ __ ] they're eating drinking or smoking
i'll say it again the first one will
work because if it's just mediocre but
the marketing is phenomenal 98 of the
world are gonna [ __ ] smoke it and not
know that it's mediocre all of you do
that every day
i love everybody's faces like nah i was
like you do that every day every one of
you is eating or drinking something
mediocre compared to the person that
actually knows what the [ __ ] going on
in that category and you don't give a
[ __ ]
so both
because a great great great product with
mediocre marketing you can always fix
the marketing and if the product's
[ __ ] the best it's always got to shop
[Music]
stay well thank you thank you so much
i watch your instagram all the time man
appreciate that yeah i i i like
everything you do thank you and positive
my name
thank you for the love bro yeah
yeah for real
no no no no i don't smoke i don't smoke
i don't know i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
a pleasure it's a pleasure to meet you
like [ __ ] legend like what the [ __ ]
congratulations i can't even believe i'm
here right now what's most on your mind
um i mean [ __ ] i've been going on i've
been touring sold out shows everything's
amazing i'm independent didn't have a
manager until recently so right now that
it's finally everything's trying to like
starting
going through a breakup so new cycles
single
[ __ ] [ __ ] it up
so when you look back at the history of
liquor industry
when i think about the next five or ten
years
i think about 1940 1945 1950 1955 1960
liquor industry if you look at the 1950s
to the 60s so much of what the liquor
industry is today
across all 50 states was really built
from that era i think that's what is
gonna happen right now in cannabis this
next five ten years a lot of the
pretenders are gonna shake out
a lot of the real dogs are gonna mature
they're gonna go from puppies to
grown-up dogs and i you know when i
think about the next five or ten years i
think it's the steel and the concrete is
hardening and then 20 30 years from now
we'll decorate the rooms but the
foundation's being built right now i
don't understand why people don't want
to be nice to each other there's no
[ __ ] logical reason to not be nice to
each other ever
nobody here is gonna strip game to me
and tell me why it's nice or appropriate
to not be nice it makes no [ __ ] sense
we need way more [ __ ] kindness we are
in a society right now where people
think when you get hate you deploy hate
back you get you want to win when you
get hate deployed love back because that
person's [ __ ] up ego is a funny word
i when i hear ego i hear insecurity
ego to me is insecurity with makeup on
i think there's a very very not fine
life and very clear line between
confidence and ego confidence is you
believe in yourself you have self-esteem
and you're accountable when you [ __ ]
lose
ego is you're trying to trick everybody
that you're good because you're not good
trying to look successful and trying to
look happy for everybody on the gram or
on tick tock or tonight with what you
wore
always
always ends up poorly you need to
actually be happy not play it on social
media i wanted to know if we could do an
overrated or underrated live
here at the great street how many okay
guys overrated or underrated french
bulldogs french troll dogs are
underrated [ __ ] they are a good ass
[ __ ] breed i like those little
[ __ ]
the men gala the met gala is overrated
legal lead in california is overrated or
underrated grossly underrated
grossly it matters it's impacting
minnesota it's impacting nevada it's
impacting and it's it's underrated for
the space
[Applause]
and every day i would run to the golden
gate bridge listen to your stuff on you
know building your side right
more so i'm doing crypto full time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right la trip is a wrap really good
times got a lot accomplished talked a
lot about a lot of subject matters
predominantly cannabis nft little social
really excited about that and now really
focused on b-con
one thing to everybody coming here what
would you say bring happiness
awesome see you guys later a week from
today at this exact moment we'll be like
be conning the [ __ ] out of it so really
excited about that obviously a year into
making a lifetime in the making so
focus on that on with dustin drock it's
been nice that's a wrap dailyvee see
[Music]